In this video we
will try to segment
an MRI brain image of
a healthy patient using
hierarchical clustering.
Make sure that you are
in the directory where
you saved the healthy.csv file.
We will be following
the exact same steps
we did in the previous video.
First, read in the data, and
call the data frame healthy.
Use the read.csv function to
read in the healthy data set.
And remember that this
healthy data set consists
of a matrix of intensity
values, so let's set the header
to false.
And now let's create
the healthy matrix using
the as.matrix function,
which takes as an input
the healthy data frame.
And now let's
output the structure
of the healthy matrix.
And then we realize
that we have 566
by 646 pixel resolution
for our image.
So this MRI image is
considerably larger
than the little flower
image that we saw,
and we worked with in
the previous two videos.
To see the MRI image, we
can use the image function
in R, which takes as an
input the healthy matrix.
And then let's
turn our axes off.
And then use the
grey-scale color scheme.
So the color is equal to
grey, which shades a sequence
of values going from zero to
one, with the length of 256.
And now going to
our graphics window,
we see that what we have
is the T2-weighted MRI
imaging of a top
section of the brain.
And it shows
different substances,
such as the gray matter,
the white matter,
and the cerebrospinal fluid.
Now let us see if we can
isolate these substances
via hierarchical clustering.
We first need to convert the
healthy matrix to a vector,
and let's call it
healthy vector.
And that is equal to S dot
vector of the healthy matrix.
And now the first
step in performing
hierarchical clustering is
computing the distance matrix.
So let's type distance equals
dist of healthy vector.
And let's specify the
method to be euclidean.
Oh, R gives us an error
that seems to tell us that
our vector is huge, and R
cannot allocate enough memory.
Well let us see how
big is our vector.
So we're going to go
and use the structure
function over the
healthy vector,
and let's see what we obtain.
Hm.
The healthy vector
has 365,636 elements.
Let's call this number n.
And remember, from
our previous video,
that for R to calculate
the pairwise distances,
it would actually need to
calculate n*(n-1)/2 and then
store them in the
distance matrix.
Let's see how big
this number is.
Wow.
Of course R would complain.
It's 67 billion
values that we're
asking R to store in a matrix.
The bad news now is that
we cannot use hierarchical
clustering.
Is there any other solution?
Well, we have seen
in lecture two
that another clustering
method is k-means.
Let us review it
first, and see if it
could work on our
high resolution image.
The k-means clustering
algorithm aims
at partitioning the
data into k clusters,
in a way that each
data point belongs
to the cluster whose mean
is the nearest to it.
Let's go over the
algorithm step-by-step.
In this example we
have five data points.
The first step is to specify
the number of clusters.
And suppose we wish to find
two clusters, so set k=2.
Then we start by randomly
grouping the data
into two clusters.
For instance, three
points in the red cluster,
and the remaining two
points in the grey cluster.
The next step is to compute
the cluster means or centroids.
Let's first compute the
mean of the red cluster,
and then the mean of the grey
cluster is simply the midpoint.
Now remember that the
k-means clustering algorithm
tries to cluster points
according to the nearest mean.
But this red point over here
seems to be closer to the mean
of the grey cluster, then to
the mean of the red cluster
to which it was assigned
in the previous step.
So intuitively, the next
step in the k-means algorithm
is to re-assign the data points
to the closest cluster mean.
As a result, now this red point
should be in the grey cluster.
Now that we moved one point
from the red cluster over
to the grey cluster, we
need to update the means.
This is exactly the next step
in the k-means algorithm.
So let's recompute the
mean of the red cluster,
and then re-compute the
mean of the grey cluster.
Now we go back to Step 4.
Is there any point
here that seems
to be cluster to a cluster mean
that it does not belong to?
If so, we need to re-assign
it to the other cluster.
However, in this
case, all points
are closest to their cluster
mean, so the algorithm is done,
and we can stop.
In the next video, we will
implement the k-means algorithm
in R to try to segment
the MRI brain image.